So there's a great book by Michael
Waltzer called what it means to be an
American,
and one of the things that he says is
that for centuries,
really from the time of the Greeks,
political philosophers believed that the
only way to have diversity in a society
was for it to be an empire or a
dictatorship.
If you wanted a democracy,
it had to be homogenous.
One ethnic group,
one racial group,
and especially one religion.
And then he ends that section and he
begins the next section with the line
until the United States of America.
We are the first mass scale,
religiously diverse democracy,
and I think that's a remarkable thing.
And when a religiously diverse democracy
works well,
it's a sight to behold.
You have low levels of prejudice.
You have strong social cohesion,
you have high levels of social capital,
you have respect for different identity
communities.
You have the narrative of a diverse
society that binds that society with a
sense of unity.
And a lot of what interfaith youth core
is about is helping America continue to
be a religiously diverse democracy that
we all ought to be proud of.
What strikes me most about the founding
fathers and a set of important figures
before the founding fathers,
people like Roger Williams and the
people who drafted the flushing
remonstrance,
that's 140 years before the founding
fathers was that this set of characters
imagined a religiously diverse democracy
and a big part of that is the separation
of church and state and as a part of
that of course is to protect the state
from the church and to protect religious
communities from undue interference by
the state and it is also significantly
about the welcoming of contributions
from diverse religious communities and
so it's not like the founding fathers
were principally very devout people,
but they recognize the importance of the
civic contributions of religious
communities and they certainly wanted
those communities to flourish.
Let me give you a couple of examples of
this.
So Benjamin Franklin,
when he lived in Philadelphia,
made proactive donations to the building
funds of every religious community that
he could find in Philadelphia.
Different communities of Christians,
a Jewish community,
and he built a hall,
said the pulpit of this hall will be
open to the preaching of anybody.
If the grand mufti of Constantinople
wants to send somebody preaching about
Islam,
this pulpit is here for his service,
right?
That's not just freedom of religion,
that's welcoming the contributions of
diverse religious communities.
George Washington,
when a Jewish leader in the late 18th
century says to him,
what's going to happen to,
to my community,
to us Jews now that we have a new
nation,
a constitution,
and you are the president.
And George Washington writes in a famous
document in American history called a
letter to the Hebrew congregation of
Newport,
Rhode Island.
He writes,
this government will give to bigotry,
no sanction and to persecution.
No assistance made the children of the
stock of Abraham sit and safety under
their own vine and fig and let there be
none to make them afraid.
So there is this sense that these
different religious communities are
going to help make up the civil society
that is the United States of America.
I think about it as a,
as a potluck nation.
And of course,
that's a play on a,
on the term melting pot.
Uh,
and what I don't like about the melting
pot is obviously this notion that,
that you have to kind of melt away your
identity or your distinctiveness.
I think what makes America strong is not
that different communities melt away
their identities.
It's that they bring their identities to
the common table in the way we think
about a potluck,
right?
And a potluck is boring if everybody
brings wonder.
Bread and peanut butter.
A potluck is wonderful and nutritious
and festive when people bring the
various dishes that are distinctive to
their identity.
That's how I think about interfaith.
America is a variety of communities.
A variety of orientations around
religion,
as I said,
from atheist to Zoroastrians,
are contributing the best of who they
are for the comments.
If different communities don't
contribute,
the nation doesn't feast.